صباح الخير اعلنا رئيس اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه يونس سيزر ارتفاع حصيله
قتلى اعداد قتل الزلزال التي ضربت ولايات
جنوبيه البلاد الى اربعين الفاستمائه
وقال سيزر ان الزلزال اثرت على ما يقرب من
عشره الاف حيث سكني في 11 ولايه جنوبيه
البلاد
وبعد اسبوعين على الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
تتبادل الحكومه والمعارضه الاتهامات
بالتقصير في مواجهه الازمه ليرشحها البعض
لتكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات المرتقبه
في تركيا توصل الاحزاب المعارضه توجيها
الانتقادات لسياسه الحكومه في التعاطي مع
الزلزال لتؤكد بان حجم الكارثه اظهر عجزا
في التعاطي معها فعواقب الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب عده مدن تركيه ستستمر طويلا
وستكون النقطه الابرز على حملات
الانتخابات التشريعيه والرئاسيه التي
ستعقد خلال اشهر وتاخذها حكومه اردوغان
على انها التحدي الاكبر للتخفيف من
تداعيات الزلزال المدمر
وفق تقرير نشرته وكاله بلومبرك قال احد
زعماء المعارضه ان تراكم السلطه السياسيه
بيد اردوغان وضعف الاستجابه السريعه اعاق
جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
وباتت السلطات اقل كفاءه من جديد غير ان
الحكومه ردت ووصف التصريحات الاحزاب
المعارضه بغير اللائقه داعيه في الوقت
نفسه لتظفر كافه الجهود مع تزايد حده
التممل والاستياء في وسط المواطنين مشيره
ان اردوغان اقر ببطء الاستجابه للزلزال
وان تحقيقا سيفتح لمعرفه الاسباب
الزلزال الذي ادى لانهيار الاف البنايات
وتسبب في مقتل العشرات وتشريد الملايين
يمكن ان يكون ورقه مهمه في الانتخابات
وماده للتنفس بين اردوغان واحزاب المعارضه
جو مشحون بالتوترات السياسيه وحتى
الاقتصاديه تنظر بانتخابات صعبه على
الطرفين خصوصا اذا توافقت المعارضه ونجحت
بتقديم مرشح مشترك لمنافسه اردوغان
يصل اليوم وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن
الى تركيا في زياره رسميه لاول مره
وسيلتقبلين نظيره التركي مولود اوغلو
لمناقشه سبل تقديم المساعده عقب وقوع
الزلزال المدمر والذي تسبب بمقتل اكثر من
سبعه واربعين الف شخص في تركيا وسوريا
وترك اكثر من مليون شخص بلا ماوى
منذ اللحظات الاولى لانتشال الطفل السوريه
عفراء من تحت الانقاض في جنديرس وبعد ان
تمت معالجتها في احد المستشفيات قرب عفرين
والتحقق من هويتها وهويه اقاربها جرى لما
شمل الطفل الرضيعه وتسليمها الى عمتها
وزوجها وسمياها عفراء على اسم والدتها
المتوفى الى جانب افراد اسرتها في كارثه
الزلزال المدمر وقال زوج العمه خليل
السواد ان هذه الطفله تعني الكثير له
ولاسرته مضيفا انها ستبقى ذكرى له ولزوجته
ولجميع الاقارب في قريه والديها
والله ما ينصف فرحه هاي يعني صار لها عشره
ايام شفتني عايش على اعصابي يعني عم استنى
هاللحظه هاي والحمد لله
معي زوجتي وابني
والحمد لله يعني يعني كله قانوني امورنا
كلها قانونيه صارت اجراءات كلها قانونيه
افاد مراسل العربيه بان القوات الروسيه
تتقدم الى شمال شرق باخموت وتحاول اقتحام
بلده
قبل ذلك اعلن او قصفت القوات الاوكرانيه
منطقه كيفزكي وبلده مجاوره في جمهوريه
الانفصاليه باثنتي عشره قذيفه مدفعيه مع
الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم وذلك وفق
مكتب مراقبه وتنسيق القضايا المتعلقه
بجرائم الحرب في اوكرانيا من جانبه دمر
الجيش الروسي معقلا للقوات الاوكرانيه في
لوغونس شرق اوكرانيا بصاروخين حراريين
وفقا لتقارير اعلاميه
من دنيت معنا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا ما تفاصيل هذا
القصف الجديد
صباح الخير فاطمه يعني بالفعل تستمر
الاعمال العسكريه هنا في الشرق الاوكراني
وفي مناطق مختلفه من اوكرانيا حيث يعني
تجري في هذه الايام عمليه عسكريه روسيه
كبيره تحاول روسيا التقدم والسيطره اكثر
على بلدات ومدن في جميع المحاور اذا كانت
الجنوبيه وحتى الشرقيه كان الحديث عن
دانياسك ولوغانسك او المحور الشمالي من
دانياتك وحده يعني يوم امس تحدثت الدفاع
الروسيه عن سيطره الجيش الروسي على احدى
البلدات في محيط خارك وان الجيش الروسي
مازال يتقدم نحو لمان
وكوبيانسك المدينتين اللتان فقدهما الجيش
الروسي وانسحب منهما خلال الاشهر الماضيه
هناك عوده كبيره للجيش الروسي فاطمه نرى
هنا في منطقه دانياس وجود كبير وكثافه
الاعداد الجنود المستجدين القادمين من
روسيا ذلك بعد المكافات التي اعلنتها
موسكو واعلنتها قوات فاغنر الخاصه الحديث
عن
البدء بثلاثه الاف دولار كمستحقات لكل
جندي تصل الى خمسه وسته الاف دولار
كراتب يعني مستحقات ماليه للجندي الذي
يذهب فقط للقتال ثلاثه اشهر للتدريب ومن
ثم للقتال بالفعل هناك رغبه كبيره عند
المواطنين الروس للذهاب الى المعارك من
اجل الحصول على مستحقات ماليه بالدرجه
الاولى وبالدرجه الثانيه يعني هي قضيه لهم
تعتبر على الارض تتقدم قوات فاغنر كما
اسلفتي في
تفضلي كنت اسالك رائد عن الاسلحه الحديثه
التي اتت بها روسيا الى ارض المعركه ايضا
بالفعل روسيا طورت الاسلحه المستخدمه في
المعارك ودعمتها جيش الروسي على سبيل
المثال كانت تستخدم دبابات سوفيتيه الان
نزلت الدبابه الحديثه
90 الى ارض المعارك وباتت تعمل هنا كذلك
المقاتلات الحديثه دخلت الى اجواء المعركه
حسب القياده العسكريه الروسيه كما ان
صواريخ التي تطلق من
راجمات الصواريخ او حتى القذائف التي تطلق
من المدافع بتنا نسمع اصوات غريبه حقيقه
نحن لا نميز سوى بين القصف من قبل الجانب
الروسي او سقوط القذيفه الاوكرانيه حولنا
لكن اليوم نسمع اصوات انفجارات غريبه يعني
كل صاروخ وله دوي انفجار او اطلاق مختلف
عن الاخر فبالفعل بدنا نسمع اصوات غريبه
وهي بالفعل تلك الاسلحه التي دعم بها
الجيش الروسي المقاتلين على الجبهات
بالفعل هناك ايضا تعداد كبير للمقاتلين
على الجبهات اي ان الجيش الروسي بات اذا
لم يكن يساوي اعداد المقاتلين الاوكرانيين
الذين يدافعون عن المدن التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني باتت اعداد اعداد الجيش
الروسي اكبر رغم ان المقارنه كانت كبيره
كانت المقارنه تساوي ثمانيه الى واحد
لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه لكن بعد التعبئه
الجزئيه التي اعلنتها موسكو العام الماضي
بات هناك توازن على الاقل باعداد
المقاتلين وكثافه كبيره
بالاسلحه حيث هناك نقص بالاسلحه
الاوكرانيه يعني كانت المدينه هنا او
المقاطعه بشكل عام تقصف
هناك قصف عنيف اظن ان القصف يعني اظن ان
هذا اطلاق نار روسي كانت المقاطعه هنا
فاطمه تقصف بمئات الصواريخ والقذائف وصولا
الى 500 قذيفه بشكل متوسط لكن اليوم
الحديث عن 45 قذيفه وصاروخ فقط سقطت على
المنطقه او المقاطعه كامله وهذا يرجعه
المراقبون والخبراء الى نقص الذخيره عند
جانب الاوكراني بسبب قصف الجيش الروسي
لمستودعات الذخيره المستمر بشكل يومي تعلن
الدفاع الروسيه عن قصفها لمستودعات
الذخيره ولمنصات صواريخ هايمرز
لمدافع هاوزر اضافه الى تحييدها لاعداد
كبيره من الجنود والاليات ما زالت
العمليات
الجيش الروسيه
تستنفذ الذخيره اكثر واسرع مما يمكن
توفيرها لها شكرا لك من دنيتك مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر
اوضح مسؤول امريكي الرفيع المستوى ان
روسيا استخدمت مسيرات صينيه في حربها في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر جمع معلومات
استخباراتيه من كيف مؤكدا ان روسيا قادره
على رؤيه التكتيكات والتقنيات والاجراءات
بما في ذلك كيفيه استجابه الطائرات من دون
طيار لهجمات الحرب الالكترونيه بحسب ما
نقلت صحيفه
من ان هذه الطائرات لا تغذي فقط المجهود
الحربي الروسي ولكنها تسمح ايضا للصين
بجمع معلومات استخباراتيه حاسمه في ساحه
المعركه
سلطنه عمان اعلنت عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه بقوه
4.1 درجات على مقياس ريختر وذلك وفقا
لمركز رصد الزلازل في جامعه السلطان قابوس
فان الهزه سجلات او سجلات في مدينه الدقم
على الساحل الجنوبي الشرقي للسلطنه وبين
المركا وبين المركز ان الشعور بالهزه كان
خفيفا في الدقم وغير محسوس في المدن
الاخرى بما فيها العاصمه مسقط
نتابع بعض الفاصل
15 قتيلا في هجمات صاروخيه اسرائيليه في
كفر سوسه ومناطق محيطه بالعاصمه السوريه
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان بان ضربه جويه اسرائيليه استهدفت
منطقه كفر سوسه في قلب العاصمه السوريه
دمشق مؤكدا وقوع 15 قتيلا على الاقل جراء
تلك الغارات بينما تحدث جيش النظام السوري
عن سقوط خمسه قتله بينهم جندي في الهجوم
[موسيقى]
حديقه البناء حياتنا
ضربه واحده في دمشق على الاقل في منطقه
المزرعه هناك دمار في منزل ومعلومات عن
خسار بشريه في كفر سوسو منزل منهاره بشكل
شبه كامل في هذا الحي او هذه المنطقه التي
يوجد فيها مركز ايراني ثقافي او احد
المراكز التابعه للايرانيين ايضا كان هناك
انفجار شديد في جنوب دمشق المنطقه الواقعه
بين السيده زينب
والمطار وايضا كان هناك في محافظه
السويداء يوجد دفاعات جويه جرى استهدافها
في كفر سوسه مثل ما قلنا المدرسه
الايرانيه هل سقط الصاروخ بالفعل على
المدرسه الايرانيه ام على مبدا بالقرب
المدرسه الايرانيه اذا ما كان الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي بمبنى هذا يدل بان اسرائيل
لديها معلومات عن وجود شخصيه ما ايرانيه
او لحزب الله او شخصيه مهمه حقيقه الامر
في تونس تطوير مرحله للايقاف الايقافات
التي قامت بها الاجهزه الامنيه تطوي
اسبوعها الاول وقد شملت قيادات من الصف
الاول في النهضه وناشطين سياسيين رجال
اعمال وقضاه معزولين وقيادات امنيه وفي
وقت يؤكد الرئيس سعيد ان الاعتقالات على
صله بمتهمين بالتامر على امن الدوله يرى
معارضوه ان الخطوه هي تصفيه لخصوم سياسيين
ايقافات ستتلوها اخرى هكذا ينطلق القضاء
التونسي في التعامل مع متهمين بالاعتداء
على امن الدوله قيادات محسوبه على النهضه
من سياسيين وامنيين ورجال اعمال وقضاه
معزولين هم الان رهن الايقاف والسجن في
انتظار استكمال مسار الاصلاح بعد
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هكذا يتحدث الشارع
التونسي المشغول بهموم قوت يومه من الندور
تلقى الازمات راهم اللي هما كانهم الدوله
مويزيه معناها مش معناها المسؤولين قاعدين
يحكموا هم قائمين بدور الدوله الموازيه
الايقافات متاخره برشا طريقه ايقافات هي
اللي متشرفش الشعب التونسي ومتشرفش الثوره
التونسيه وما تشرفش التضحيات التوانسه عبر
التاريخ يؤكد الرئيس سعيد في رد على
منتقديه من الداخل والخارج ان مطلب
المحاسبه الشعبيه وان كل الاجراءات
قانونيه محترمه زياده الدوله واحده كما
يقول
لسنا تحت الاستعمار او الحمايه او
الانتداب نحن دوله مستقله
ذات سياده
الا ان مساله سياده الدوله تثار عند
المتابعين بين عملي اجهزتها للحفاظ على
استمرار الدوله او العوده الى مربع
الارتهان للخارج او الدخول الى منطقه
الفوضى عندهم نتحدث عن ايقافات اليوم يجب
ان نتجاوز مساله مجرد المناوشات السياسيه
طبيعه الاسماء التي اوقفت في القضيه تحيل
الى قضيه امن دوله بامتياز بمعنى هناك
مخطط لاسقاط السلطه القائمه لم يتوانى
القائمون به على التصحيح به علنا يعني
هناك من قال لرئيس الجمهوريه لديك مهله
للخروج الامن هناك من استنجد بالاجهزه
لاسقاط الدوله
ورغم الجدل المثار اليوم حول الايقافات
الاخيره الا ان جل المتابعين يؤكدون انها
محطه اخرى على درب تعديل البوصله واستكمال
الخيار الاصلاحيه والاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في البلاد وا القوس منظومه الاخوان
والفساد وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس من
المرتقب ان توقع
القطره المحدثه لاتفاق جب اليوم وبحضور
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
ورئيس جنوب السودان سلفاكير البرهان قال
ان الجيش ليس مواليا لاي حزب
الجيش
والاموال
احنا حابين الشعب السوداني ده
في مجموعات بتحاول تصطاد وتحاول تتبنى
مواقف للجيش الجيش ما عندهم
موقفه ولا هو بنى له موقف حزب الجيش مؤسسه
مستغله اذا دخلت في سياسه بتخرب البلد
اذا دخلت السياسه في الجيش بتحب الجيش
عشان كذا بنبعد
الجيشين اذا كانوا
في ناس استغلوا الكلام اللي احنا قلناه
المره اللي فاتت
عدو لفئه معينه نحن ما عدو لا عدو للحريه
ولا التغيير لا عدو للكتله الوطنيه
والاموالين لدول كل الناس سودانيين وعندنا
زي بعض ودارينهم يتفقوا عشان البلد دي
تمشي للامام
قالت كوريا الشماليه انها اختبرت صاروخا
باليستيا عابرا للقارات في البحر قباله
الساحل الغربي لليابان وذلك بعد ظهر امس
واكدت استعدادها لهجوم مضاد نووي قاتل ضد
القوات المعاديه وقالت وكاله الانباء
الحكوميه ان الصاروخ اجتازت 989 كلم خلال
67 دقيقه وبلغ اقصى ارتفاع له
5,768 كيلومتر قبل ان يصيب بدقه منطقه
محدده مسبقا في المياه المفتوحه
طلب الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جيمي مغادره
المستشفى بعد قضائه فترات متقطعه للعلاج
هناك ونقله الى بيته العائلي لقضاء ماء
تبقى له من وقت مع افراد اسرته وسيتلقى
الذي يبلغ 98 عاما رعايه في بيته وهو
يعاني منذ سنوات من سلسله من المشكلات
الصحيه التي تطلبت دخوله المستشفى مرات
عده منذ العام 2019
اعلنت السلطات نيوزلنديه عن ارتفاع عدد
قتلى اعصار جابرييل الى 11 شخصا وفقدان
اكثر من 5000 شخص بعد اسبوع من اجتياح
الاعصار الجزيره الشماليه والذي تسبب ايضا
من قطاع الكهرباء عن نحو 62 الف منزل
وقدمت السلطات الطوارئ والجيش امدادات
حيويه من طائرات هليكوبتر الى بلدات تقطعت
بها السبل منذ وقوع الاعصار
الى العناوين
حاصله قتل الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا تتجاوز
47 الفا والمعارضه التركيه تتهم الحكومه
بالتقصير
قصف مدفعي اوكراني على دونيسكو الجيش
الروسي يدمر معقلا للقوات الاوكرانيه
تطلق صاروخا باليستيا عابرا للقارات وتقول
انه ضمن تدريب مفاجئ
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]